hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited to
show you guys what i have on my computer
right now i am beyond ecstatic and i say
this a lot about being excited about
things but this is something very
special almost every single video that
you have seen me make over the past like
five to six years i have been using
plugins from motion vfx from my titles
to my end cards to transitions like
everything has come from this company
and just kind of sitting here and
reflecting they have had such a huge
impact on my video career and they've
saved me so much time because i just use
their plugins they're so easy to use so
customizable which brings me to today's
announcement that i partnered with them
on their m keynote with ijustine plugin
pack and i could not be more excited
because this has a bunch of things that
i have been looking for in a pack and
they're all here the best part about
these is they're so customizable so
something that you might see me use you
could use that same plugin but make it
look completely different and i am
beyond excited to show you these now i'm
using final cut pro which is what i've
been editing in for quite a long time
but this pack is also available for
premiere and davinci resolve so i'm
gonna put a link in the description to
check it out and it's very easy to set
up there's a little program called m
installer which you install that which
allows you to have an entire library of
all of your plugins so not only do they
have m keynote they have a ton of others
they make it super easy to install and
update so it isn't just like hey you
installed this once and then they don't
do updates all of the plugins that i
have previous that worked on my intel
mac they have been all upgraded for m1
which is very exciting so once you have
it installed it'll show up here in your
titles under and keynote we're going to
go through each of these just so you can
kind of see and get a sense of what
these look like it brings a ton of
minimalist designs and animations all
into one really great pack as a content
creator and video editor motion vfx has
been my number one go-to for all of my
plugins and animations in my videos over
the past couple of years so i'm so
excited to partner with them to bring
you guys m keynotes and if you guys
don't know i'm a huge fan of apple and
all of their keynote presentations
because they have such a clean minimal
design so we brought the best of both
worlds and put them all in one into this
really easy to use plug-in pack we have
these beautiful backgrounds that vary
from different colors to animations to
even this one which i love so much it's
the blurred background i use this
feature a lot in some of my videos to
blur the backgrounds and then put text
over top but with this it's super simple
to do we just drag and drop and you
automatically have that blur in and blur
out of your background there's a
selection of boards which will allow you
to add various types of texts titles
animations graphics like this one for
example is you can change the type of
social network so let's go to youtube
and since i just hit seven million
subscribers check that out
there's a bunch of really fun call to
action like this one that says buy but
of course if you don't want to say bye
all of the text and colors are all
customizable something that i do a lot
for my videos in tech reviews is there's
always a ton of specs and it gets a
little tedious to go and edit those and
make new graphs i'm not going to have to
do that anymore because there's an
entire section for infographics we have
different types of bar charts we even
have a calendar i like this for release
dates of when products are coming out
various line graphs different types of
progress bars and last but not least we
have specs and traits this is going to
be perfect when i'm detailing out
different types of specs for products
that i'm reviewing there's some logo
animations and these are so easy to use
if you already have a logo all you have
to do is drop it right here into the
drop zone and instantly your logo is
animated i really love the miscellaneous
section this has so many fun little
things we have a clock we have a locate
pin number progress bar we have a tag a
smart cloud and a website address this
next section is placeholders this is
something that i am so excited about i
always try to lay out different photos
and videos and i can never actually get
them to line up perfectly about this i
can choose which template i like and
then i can drag and drop in each piece
of footage whether it's a video or a
photo and everything is lined up
perfectly again it's all customizable
and extremely easy to use i think these
all look really great i love the rounded
edges on a lot of these and i really
like this placeholder 7 because this
gives you 10 different drop zones and
it'll make it super easy to be able to
drag and drop in all of your footage
photos videos and have them all line up
perfectly the typography section is a
huge part of this pack as well there are
so many different options to choose from
i love adding text to my videos when i'm
talking about something just to add some
extra emphasis also sometimes just
sitting here talking on a blank wall can
get a little boring so let's spice it up
with a little bit of text or a lot a bit
of text it's really hard to say you can
really do whatever you want that's the
beauty of it so my friends that is a
first look at m keynote this is
obviously inspired by my love of
minimalist design and typography and all
things apple so i'm very excited for you
guys to get a chance to check this out i
look forward to seeing it in some of
your future projects
[Music]